last one
the composer Brian Tyler who's a huge
Mario fan I've been playing since I was
a kid so you can hear the Mario music
playing in the game but in your mind
it's like a whole other world
I wanted to capture that feeling I had
when I was a kid growing up playing
[Music]
as Brian and I talked about a variety of
things I learned that he had been a fan
of Nintendo games since he was a boy so
he was the perfect composer for the
movie The Original music for Mario game
is immediately recognizable and
sometimes it's just a little hint here
or a little flourish there
I wanted to pay homage to that to bring
that into the world of cinematic
experience